من الان نذهب لمتابعه هذه الكلمه لرئيس
الفرنسيه
الاسلحه
حضره اعضاء البرلمان وزير الدوله
الرئيسه الهيئه وزير الدفاع الوطني
المسؤول عن التسلح الوزير الخارجيه بنسبه
الاداره رئيس هيئه الاركان مع لمدير العام
للشرطه الوطنيه مديره العلاقات العامه
والاستراتيجيه
حضرتك اكبر الضباط الضباط ضباط الصفا
الجنود في البحاره الملاحون الطيارون
حضره السيدات والساده انا مسرور لملاقاتكم
اليوم هنا
حامله الطائرات
من العام 2018
فطبعا نحن نتحدث
حضره رئيس البلديه عن اننا متواجدون هنا
في هذا المبنى في هذا اليوم هذا ولكن لا
يجدر بنا ان ظننا ان هذه الفتره هي فتره
هادئه فان الحرب موجوده في الاراضي
الاوروبيه وهي في خطر التصاعد وتداعياتها
سيكون لها اثر عالمي فهي تختفي
وهي تحاول ان تخفي عقدا من الهدوء فهي
فهذه الحرب ايضا تظهر قفزه لا مثير لها في
هذا العالم لانها قديمه مثل الحرب فانا
بعد القوه
حاولت ان تربط بين اثار الحرب مع العصر
الرقمي فان العدوان على اوكرانيا على
اوكرانيا عفوا
يشركوا على ان يترك تداعيات في عقبال فنحن
لا يمكننا ان نقبل هذا بدون ان نحرك ساكن
انا لا يمكننا ان نكون هادئين اتجاه هذا
ولكن هذه الامور بالنسبه حلف شمال الاطلسي
لم تكن جديده وهذه الامور ليست جديده
بالنسبه لنا فقمنا بالتحدث عنها في
المراجعه الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه ونحن ذكرنا
انه لابد ان نتخذ اجراءات وجهودا لحمايه
انفسنا والحمايه سيادتنا في ظل الفضاء
الحالي في ظل المعلومات السريانيه وفي ظل
المساحه
البحريه وايضا في قعر البحار فيجدر بنا ان
نواجهما نطلقه عليه اذا لا تهديدات
التي تشكل اكثر الخطورات حاليا فان
التحليل بالاستينات الى كل هذه
الاستنتاجات
الموضوع
مرتبطه باعاده تسليح امتنان مثل ما قررنا
منذ خمسه اعوام وطبعا انا اشعر بالرضا
لاكلها لكم اليوم ان هذه الالتزامات تم
الافاء بها فتم الافاء بالتزاماتنا بفضل
عملكم بفضل جهودكم بفضل تفانيكم وبفضل عمل
جميع اعضاء البرلمان فانا اتقدم بالشكر لك
فتال الوزراء الكافئين الذين حرصوا على ان
يكونوا هنا وحرص على على مطلعين على ارشد
المستحدثات ولكن للاسف اذا تغيرت الامور
في منطقتنا ولكن الالتزامات تم الافاق بها
فان مسود الماليه لعام 2013 تشهد على ذلك
انا اشعر بالفخر وان جيشا ايضا يستحق الث
فنحن لابد ان نقول انه بالنسبه للقدراتنا
بالنسبه لما فعلناها كان ضروريا ان ننفق
كل ما انفقناه نفذ لكل جهود ولكن لابد ان
نبني المستقبل ان ما يحصل في اوكرانيا ليس
فقط
ميلان حديثا فكان هنالك تصارعا كثيفا وكان
لابد ايضا من ان نعرف ما حصل فانا
الملايين الاشخاص اذن همم الاف الاشخاص
توفوا طبعا هنالك اسلحه جديده
ترافقت مع اسلحه فتاكه قديمه وادت الى
وفاه الا في الاشخاص في هذه الحرب فان هذه
الحرب ايضا
تصليت الضوء على حاله العالم الذي نعيشها
الان فان هنالك ضعفا في القواعد في احترام
القواعد همم وهذا يشكل افطرنا لانه تم
التشكيك بالتوازن السابق ولم يتم ايجاد
توازن جديد فهذا التسارع الماساوي جعل
ضروريه ان نحيد ان نعيد مراجعه
التفكير في استراتيجياتنا وقمنا بهذه
العمليه طبعا
البوصله الاستراتيجيه الذي نقشناها في
اطار الاتحاد الاوروبي وتحت رئاسه
الجمهوريه الفرنسيه
منذ شهر ديسمبر كانون الاول من عام 2019
فنحن ايضا لابد ان نعيد اقتراح رؤيه جديده
لكيفيه التعامل مع التهديدات ولهذا السبب
سيتم اطلاق قانون برمجه جديد بامكانه ان
يهيا جيوشنا اذا في شهر الصعيد
الى اعاده التفعيل التي حصلت تم بذل جهود
من اجل
اعاده التفكير في المراجعه الاستراتيجيه
الوطنيه التي ستشكل اساس قانون البرمجه
العسكريه القادم لهذا السبب اودو ان اتقدم
بالشكر الى وزير الاسلحه طبعا الى وزير
اسئله وزير الدفاع
والامن الوطني
وزيره اوروبا وشؤون الخارجيه لكافه الجهود
التي بدلوها ولحشق كل مصادرهم
بالشكر لاعضاء البرلمان
لاعضاء اللجان الذين تم تشاوروا معهم
اثناء هذه المراجعه على استراتيجيه
الوطنيه الذين شلبوا خبراتهم وسماحه
هذه المراجعه طبعا ان الرهان يحتم علينا
النسكافيه ده من الحاضر حتى نهيا انفسنا
لمستقبلنا القادم وطبعا عندما تحدث عن
الشيوش هيا انفسنا العوام المقبله اللي ما
يمكنها ان يهيئنا لهذه العقود التي ستاتي
وانا ادرك انكم جميعا
مدركون لهذه النقطه فلنحن تحدثنا مع بعضنا
مع بعض عندنا العمق
الاستثمارات وطبيعه الاستثمارات التي
نحتاجها لمستقبل لهذا السبب
في حال كان الوقت حاليفنا واذا ما حتى مات
علينا رؤيتنا ان نتخذ التزامات جباره يجدر
بنا ان نلبي احتياجات اليوم واحتياجات
المستقبل ولكن نظرا للهواتف والمشاغل لابد
ان تذكره دوما ان جيشنا في العام 2030
الذي لا بد ان نبنيه اليوم
الرجال والنساء والقدرات الذين سيتحلون
بها طبعا ربما لن تشبهها الجيش المثالي
الذي تحدثنا عنه في العام 20 22 ولكن نظرا
للرهان المستقبل
20/03 لهذا السبب ان اقول ان عملنا اليوم
مهم جدا في العام 2017 عندما تحدثت عن
النموذج الجيش
من ما حدث في العام 2001
في صراع العالم ضد الارهاب وكان ذلك
المسرح مسرح العالم لمكافحه الارهاب هو ما
سمح لنا بوضع النموذج في ذلك العام
والارهاب لم ينتهي طبعا ونحن لا نزال
نحارب ضد الارهاب وهو لا يداله في الصلب
نضالنا ولكن الظروف قد تغيرت نحن طبعا
اشعلنا نموذجنا اكثر صرامه
لاننا نود ان همم
ولكن لا يزال هنالك تحديات قائمه اليوم
ستبقى معنا للمستقبل
السلام عندما يعود السلام الى اوكرانيا
يجدر بنا ان ان نتعلم نستفيد من ما حصل
بنا ان نبنيه
عن حق
بنيتنا بنيت سلام وامان حقيقيه واطار
متجددا من الاستقرار
مرتبط بعد التسلح حيث ستكون اوروبا في وسط
الطاولات ايضا ان افكره في تحديات
المستقبل في المخاطر
الحروب التي قد تشتغل في المستقبل
التوترات المتزايده في اسيا
الاستخدام
المعمر للطائرات بدون مروحيه حتى في
المجالات التي لا تزال نادرا ايضا همم
التصدي الصواريخ
التعامل مع صواريخ
بالاضافه الى تكنولوجيا تصدق الصناعي همم
التوتر العالي وايضا المخاطر البيئيه
وبيتنا حيث هناك الكثير من المخاطر
البيئيه فيجدر همم ان نستفيد همم من
الدوره 27 الندم مؤتمر الاطراف في مصر فلا
بد ان نواجه التغير المناخي في السابق
عندما كنا نحاول البحث عن السلام عبر اذا
همم
الارتباط ببعضها البعض كنا نحاول ان نحميه
الاستقلال يجدر بنا ان نرتبط كل ذلك ان
يكون هنالك ثوره هائله همم
نعرف ما هي طبعا كل ما هي كل الامور
التي قامت باحداث الثوره على الصعيد
التكنولوجيا يشدون ان اخونا الاعتبار
كل ما سيحصل حتى في العام 2030 نكون قد
بنينا جيشا سيخدم العقود المقبله وليس
العقود السابقه
وينبه علينا ايضا ان نركز على الجيش ولكن
ايضا عن قطع الدفاع ولا بد ان نبنيه
المجتمع الذي يحمي سيادتنا لان من الامور
التي يجدر بنا ان نتعامل ان ان نتعلم عنها
اليوم هي كيف بامكان ان نعيد حشد هؤلاء
الاشخاص الرجال والنساء في خدمتي سيادتنا
وفي خدمه اسيادتي
اذا ما هي الرؤيه التي تنطوي عليها
المراجعه الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
ثقين تحاول ان تحافظ على التعدديه وعلى ال
حقوق الدوليه
وطبعا هنالك الكثير من المكتسبات التي
حققناها
فنحن طبعا
سنعزز اذا
مساعينا فنحن سنتمكن من العمل بفضل كل هذه
المؤسسات التي دعمتنا في السنوات الخمسه
الماضي ويجدر بناء ايضا
بفضل اهل الجهود التي
سنكتبها بنسبه المعلومات
بالاطلاع على ما يحصل من حول الخبرات
بامكاننا ان نعزيزه على الصعيد الوطني
لجمع مزيد من المعلومات الاستخبارات
والجمع المزيد من المعلومات لان المعلومات
المهمه جدا نحن سنقوم بتعزيزها وترتيبها
في المستقبل ولابد ان نتخذ القرارات بشكل
سريعا ولا بد ان نكون سريعين بالنسبه
للالتزامات ان اقول اننا نملك القوه
السياسيه منظمه الا وهي قدرتنا على ان
نقرر الان بشكل مباشر
على هذا الارض على هذه الارض الاوروبي
بامكان ان نتخذ قرارات سريعه كما لا يمكن
لاحد ان افعله نحن برهن عن ذلك في
عملياتنا التشغيليه وايضا باعاده النشر في
مانيا في الاشهر السابقه فهذه هي قوتنا
قوه
فهي تندرج ايضا ضمن اطار السياسي الذي
تحدثت عنه ولابد ايضا من تعزيز الرد على
النووي هذا النموذج
بنا نتحدث عن تعزيز الرد على النووي فان
الرد عن النووي سيكون قائما على اسس بسيطه
وواضحه تدمر حريه التصرف وتضمن وانا سنحمي
انفسنا من عدوانيه
سوري فهي
تحمينا من اي هجوم على مصالحنا الحيويه
بغض النظر عن مصدر هذا العدوان فان
مصالحنا الحيويه
تقع ضمن مسؤولياتي المسؤوليه على عاتقي
لحمايتها لتجديدها ومنذ سنتين مثل ما قلته
في
بالنسبه
لمسرح الحرب اليوم اكثر من ذي قبل ان
مصالحنا الحيوانيه مصالح فرنسا الحيويه
تتخذ طابعا اوروبيا فانا قوتنا النوويه
تساهم بفضل وجودها على حمايه سلامه فرنسا
وانما ايضا سلامه اوروبا
فانا ارى انه من المهم ان اعيد التذكير
بهذه النقطه هنا طالما احيانا يتم
الاستخفاء
بهذه الامور لابد ان نحافظ على عقيدتنا
لنحافظ على مستقينا ولا يجدر بنا ان ننسى
ان فرنسا
امين
[موسيقى]
قدرتنا على الدفاع على
ارضنا البحر
وعن مساحاتنا الارضيه هي معروفه وهي
موجوده في صلب استراتيجياتنا ولابد ان
نؤكد على هذه النقطه فانا اوروبا لم تعد
محميه فهي
عرضه ضربات من الطائرات بدون
الصواريخ فلابد ان نكون جاهزين ضد اعداءنا
لان احيانا اعداءنا ليس فقط دول هنالك
اعداء بامكانها يواجهوننا عن بعض همم
[موسيقى]
ولكن المهم ايضا ان نحمي ان نحافظ على
الحمايه الجويه لقارتنا فهذه مساله
استراتيجيه وهذه المساله لها تتعايات
متعدده لا يمكن همم ان تكون محققه بدون
الحفاظ على سياده اوروبا وبدون صناعه
دفاعيه مهمه لابد ان نفكر فيها لابد ان
نعتمد على تحليلا استراتيجي ياخذ بعين
الاعتبار كافه واحد فاعلنا فنحن سنقترح
وسنسهم
بهذا الامن استبراني ولابد في السنوات
الخمسه المقبله المطوره امننا استبرانه
بالنسبه
للمناطق ما وراء البحار هي قوه الامه وهي
مثال عن حمايتنا لحقوقنا السياديه في كافه
المحيطات نحن فرنسي
فان ما وراء البحار بالنسبه
في امريكا الجنوبيه في المحيط الهندي
وايضا في المحيط الهادي
فلا يجدر بنا ان ننسى هذه الاراضي هذه
البحار هذه المحيطات لا يجدر بما ان ننسى
الفرنسيين الذين يعيشون هناك والذين يبدون
ان يعيشوا هناك هم عرضه للتهديدات
التهديدات البيئيه او ربما تهديدات لن
اخذها بعين الاعتبار في استراتيجياتنا
العامه ولكن يجدر بنا الا ننساهم نحن
عازمون على ضمان حمايتهاما في بيئات او في
مناطق تكون احيانا مسرح عن السياسات الارض
الواقع
طبعا طبعا
لا يتجزا من سيادتنا
ونحن سنولي اهميه كبرى للتهديدات السبرنيه
فان اوروبا ايضا
تبقى النقطه الراس تبقى علما علم الذين
تضامنوا معه فنحن سنستمر في كوننا الصخره
اذا ما صح عليه القول الصخره للقوه قوه
الردعه النوويه الوحيده في اوروبا التي
تلعب دورا مهما والبوصله ايضا لنتمكن من
الحفاظ على سيادتها ان نقوم بتطوير دفاع
عن يتمتع بالمصداقيه لتعزيز دفاع حل
الاطلس
فلابد ان نفكر في الاجنده الخاصه بتدفاعه
اوروبا
اناشيد
مكتسب حققناه في السنوات الخمسه السابقه
والنستراتيجيه
ورؤيه مرتبطه بادوات
اثمرت عن نجاحتها طبعا بالنسبه
لعملياتنا قمنا ابتكار قواعد جديده
للعمليات
الاوروبيه
وجودنا فنحن قلنا بالمساعده في القوات
ادوليه
وطبعا من المهم ان نتحدث عن اشندرساي
لتعزيز سيادتنا تقليص الانفاقاتنا وحمايه
امداداتنا وتزويدنا ولابد ايضا نتحدث عن
الدعم الدفاع بفضل الصندوق دعم الدفاع
وايضا مساعده الدفاع الاوروبي المشترك اذا
ما نظرنا الى ما حققناه والى مكانتنا او
اين كنا منذ خمسه اعوام لاحظوا اننا حقنا
تقدمها عميقا بالنسبه
من هذا الموضوع ولكن لم ننهي عملنا على
العكس كل ما ذكرته يحترم علينا
زياده عملنا يحتمل علينا ان نكون صارمين
اكثر في التطبيق على الصعيد الاوروبيه
ولكن الاوروبيون جميعهم شركاء
بالاستناد الى عمليه السلامه التي حققناها
عمليه السلام التي يجدر بنا ان نعزيها
وكل هذه الشركات التي عقدناها
نقعد تحت
للالتحاق برؤيه المرتبطه بالسياده
وبالدفاعنا عن اوروبا
فان قدرتنا
ورغبتنا طبعا في تعزيز الاواصر مع المانيا
فنحن منخرطون في برامج هيكليه فانا قواتنا
موجوده
لتحشد قوتها مع بعضها البعض وايضا من
المهم ان نعمل مع بعضنا البعض على الصعيد
الطموح العمليات ومن المهم ان نشد توازنا
حتى نتمكن من انشراح المشروع الاوروبي
وانا امل ان نتمكن من اتخاذي قرارات حاسمه
في الاسابيع المقبله وامل ايضا ان نتمكن
من تعزيز بعض الشركات
تم اطلاقها في السنوات الاخيره
او بتعزيز قدراتنا
جي العملياتيه بالمضيق دوما وكنا باختبار
هذه القوه في اا نشر القوات في الاشهر
السابقه فبد ايضا
ان ننعزل شركات جديده مع ايطاليا مع
اليونان ومع الكثير من الشركاء الذين
عقدنا اتفاقيات مهمه مؤخرا مثل كرواتيا
وان نتمكن من تقديم المقترحات مع اوروبا
الغربيه
انواع جديده من الشركه انواع جديده من
التعاون التعاون الاستراتيجي على مستوى
العمليات فهذا هو اذا واجبنا ان نعرف ما
هي المقترحات التي سنقدمها لكم لهم
بالنسبه لاشكال التعاون الجديد بامكان ان
نعتمد على مستقيماتنا على قوتنا ولكن
بامكاننا ان نعتمد على ما فعلناه في
رومانيا
فان بعض هذه البلدان او هذه البلدان
الاوروبيه اعرف ان بامكانها الاعتماد على
فرنسا فان شركاتنا مع المملكه المتحده
تشكل ايضا خير مثالا على ذلك وانا امل ان
نتمكن من اعاده استئناف حوارنا حول
قدراتنا حول المجال
الهجين حول كل ما بامكان تعزيزه حتى
نقيما اذا نعزيزه صداقه وسيكون هنالك
اجتماعا ثنائي سيتم عقده في الفصل المقبل
الذي ستشهده
سيشهدها المتوسط ودول البطيخ بغض النظر
اذا كانت هذه البلدان من حيث الشمال
الاطلسي او من الاتحاد الاوروبي هنالك
شركاه وتحالفات لابد ان ابنها فان كل هذه
الجهود ستعزز قوتنا الاطلسيه فان هذا التح
الاطلسي يعتبر اثارا مهما
لامنينا فان الظروف الحاليه تسلط الضوء
على ضروره حمايه حلف شمال الاطلسي فنحن
تمكنا ان نبرهن ان اوروبا الدفاعيه اوروبا
التي تدافع بامكانها ان تعزز من حلف شمال
الاطلسي ولا تضعفه فان اوروبا
تزيده من قوه حالف شمال الاطلسي وهي تشكل
جزءا لا يتجزا منها تماما مثل اعلن روما
الذي تم عقده بين عبايات المتحده
الامريكيه وفرنسا
اليوم
سنستمر في لعب دورنا كحاليفا مثالي قادرا
على حمايه وقادرا على الاطلاع بدوره كامه
في الالتزاماتها وتضمن شركتها الشركائها
عفوا وتكون في اول من يدافع عن اوروبا
فهذا ضروري بالنسبه لحمايه مشروع اوروبا
التي تتحلى بها فرنسا ان تكون
في كل المناطق في افريقيا وفي قرن افريقيا
ايضا وفي المحيط الهادي حيث اقترحنا منذ
شهر
منذ فصل الربيع في شهر 2 2018
لا بد ان نعزز ازدهار هذه الحلقه من
التضامن من الامارات العربيه المتحده التي
تشكل شريكا نفتخر بالتعاون معه شريكا
بامكان الاعتماده عليه مرورا بالجبوتي
فنحن حريصون على الابقاء على وجودنا
وتربطنا مع جيبوتي تاريخ ويربطنا تاريخ
ولانا مستقبل ايضا انتقالا الى الهند حيث
تتمكن همم من الانقراض في شركات جديده
مرتبط بمنتهدين ايضا الى اسيا الى جنوب
اسيا والى اوكي اذا كل هذه الاستراتيجيات
هي مهمه
عزيزها لان العالم يشفق على ان ينغلق في
المستقبل نحن نشتري بنا نعتمد على
استراتيجياتنا استراتيجيه تقوم فيها فرنسا
على الدفاع عن ارضها الوطنيه وانما ايضا
دفاع عن
هذه الدفاع عن الشركائها في المنطقه
للحفاظ على
الحريه والحفاظ على سيادتها
تدركونا انتم ما اقوله الان فان تحليلنا
للوضع الحالي وتحليلنا للتهديدات يجدر به
ان
يحقق لنا التالي في المستقبل انه عيد
تشكيلا جيشنا ان نعيد التفكير في برامجنا
الكبيره
وفاتفاقياتنا ان عدا التفكير في اهدافنا
العمليه حتى نتمكن من ناحيه
ضمان حمايه ارضنا وحمايه الرعايه
الفرنسيين ونتمكن من ناحيه اخرى ان نكون
دوله
امم تشكل
جيراننا عليه شركاء انها همم نكون قادرين
على ان نعزف تحالفات
مع كافه
الشركائنا فهذا ما ستسمح لنا بالقيام به
قدرتنا وشركتنا
العسكريه
واستراتيجياتنا الوطنيه فلا بد ايضا ان
نتصرف في بعض المجالات بطريقه مختلفه
هنالك مجالات لابد ان نعيد ابتكارها ولكن
هنالك مجالات اخرى يجدر بنا ان نعزيزها
مثل ما ذكرت ومثل وعدتكم من خلال انتخابات
الرئاسي
الواقعه لابد ان نتحدث عن اعاده التفكير
في دور الامن الذي ذكرته لكم وهو يساهم في
الحمايه من النزاعات وحمايتنا في مناطق
النزاع فان
اوجه التقليديه بالاضافه الى قوتنا في
الخارج الذي احيانا بعض البلدان قد يدعون
انها تهدد سيادتهم او بعض
القوى تحاولون معلومات
الى هذه العقيده التي ذكرتها لكم بالاسناد
الى هذا الاطار المبتكر ويشدر بنا في
الاشهر الثلاثه المقبله ان نغير طريقه
عملنا بالنسبه لشركائنا في افريقيا
في طريقه همم
ولا ان تدعم
جيشهم الافريقي وذلك من خلال جهاز اكثر
تكاملا معهم لهذا السبب في الايام المقبله
سنطلق مرحله تبادل لان مع حلفائن
الافريقيين وحلفاءنا الاقليميين لنتمكن من
ايجاجه لكي الجديده او النوع الجديد
والشكل الجديد القوات الفرنسيه في الساحه
في غرب افريقيا حتى نتمكن من بناء منظمه
مشتركه ومتبادله من الدعم لدعم جيش
المنطقه فان هذه الاستراتيجيه سيتم
الانتهاء من وضع اللمسات النهائيه عليها
في غضون السته اشهر بالاستناد الى ما نرغب
في تحقيقه فهذه النقطه المهمه
وهي من الانسولات التي استخلصناها مما
عصرناه في منطقه الساحل في هذه السنوات
الاخيره ولابد لتدخلات ان تكون
طرزات صله مع وقتنا وحاضرنا فطبعا نحن
سنبقى منخرطين بدون اي اطار زمنيه في
عملياتنا الخارجيه ولهذا السبب ان قررته
بتشاور مع شركائنا بالاعلان بشكل رسمي عن
انتهاء عمليه برخان فان دعمنا العسكري
لافريقيا والاشكائنا في افريقيا سيستمر
ولكن جديده قمنا بتحديدها معها همم طبعا
سيتغير وفقا
لاحتياجات الشركائنا الاحتياجات التي يعبر
عنها شركائنا بالنسبه للتدريب بالنسبه
لمساعدتها على الناحيه
وبالنسبه لمساعداتهم لتحقيق استراتيجياتهم
الخاصه ونحن ايضا سنستمر في دعم الجهود
المدنيه التي تبذلها السلطات
الافريقيه
للتعامل مع الهشاشه
المدنيه ومع كل المشاكل من اجل مواجهه
الارهابيين فان شركتنا هي شركه حقيقيه على
مستوى الدفاع تقوم بالتربيه همم
تعبر عنه البلدان
الافريقيه وهي تاخذ معنا الاعتبار الشركات
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والاداريه في هذه
البلدان فيجددين ان نعيد التفكير طبعا في
طريقه عملنا ليس فقط بالنسبه لنشرنا
لقواتنا في الخارج ولكن ايضا بالنسبه
لعزيزنا في الداخل
فان هذه المراجعه الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه
سنقوم بها حتى نتمكن من ضمان حريه الجيش
بشكل
كبير
هو تغيير منظور
وكيف ينبغي علينا ان نستثمر وما هي الامور
التي يجدر بنا ان نفعلها في المستقبل انا
ذكرتها هذا في اننا في افريقيا بطريقه اذن
مستتره همم اذا احيانا بفضل بعض المعلومات
المضل
معلومات ثم نشرها من قبل اذ اذا
الكثير من الجيش
على الانترنت من قبل كثير من اعداءنا كان
هناك تشكيل
وذلك وقد هدد سلامتنا فيجدر بنا ايضا ان
نحمي انفسنا من هذه الهجمات التي حاولت ان
تؤجل من بعض الصراعات نحن لن نكون متفرجين
هادئين يشدون بناء ان نتمكن
من تحديد هذه
رئيس الفرنسيه من الماك